we catch up with you here in south
africa your last stop on your first
africa trip you started in senegal you
went on to niger your predecessor angela
merkel put a focus on africa what does
it feel like for you now to touch down
here for the first time as german
chancellor
africa is the continent
next to europe and it is
of essence that we work intensely to
have very good relations with all the
states in africa and also it is
important that we develop
our relations with all the democratic
states on the globe democracy the rule
of law questions that are important for
us are not just something that is
linked with the so-called western
countries it's also
very important if we look at all the
countries in the world so south africa
is a democracy senegal new year and this
is why i visited them and why i think it
is important that we
continue to work together
saying that the world has a good future
if we cooperate
if we understand that there will be a
lot of very
relevant states in the future in the 50s
of this century and that we should now
make it feasible that there is a good
cooperation that we can create a
multilateral world
now the shadow of the ukraine conflict
looms large here
this is europe being very much busy with
itself there's a war in europe
and at the same time here many countries
particularly those that you visited
are set to feel the brunt of the effects
there's a looming hunger crisis
fuel shortages fertilizer shortages
what responsibility does germany feel
to save countries that have nothing to
do with this conflict from the effects
first
russian russia
invaded ukraine
started a brutal war against the
neighbor country and so it is important
that we stick together to give the
ukraine the chance to defend itself its
integrity its sovereignty
and this is also important for peace on
the globe we should agree that there
should never again
be a successful attempt to
change borders
with force and this is what
russia is trying to do and this is why
we cannot accept this and this is why so
many countries are supporting ukraine
with financial means with
weapons also and
we developed the sanctions regime
against russia
to convince the russian leadership that
they should go away from the war that
they should start
negotiations with the ukraine and that
they
withdraw their troops from ukraine
territory where they invaded
the country
and on the other hand it is obviously
that
it is obvious that a lot of countries
are suffering from this war and from the
russian aggression and this is why we
are
very
decided that we will help the countries
that are suffering this is why we
started to cooperate in fighting against
all the consequences of
having not enough food of
supporting the countries with their own
economic difficulties they have and this
is why we also speak about how we can
work together in this very difficult
crisis but the best thing to do is
ending the war and if russia stopped its
aggression and
would
be ready for a peace this would be the
best for the whole globe what concrete
assistance can countries like for
instance sudan somalia niger expect
we are working on
supporting the world food programme and
we are
starting to gather an initiative against
the shortages that are coming
up now and we will work together with
the countries on the uni global level
together with the united nations
and this is what we are
trying to convince all
other countries that have the means to
do so to do together with us your trade
minister robert harbeck also spoke about
a u.s eu initiative
to
lower fuel prices worldwide can you
flesh that out of it
we will have
a
very difficult situation if we look at
fuel prices
obviously this will be not feasible to
subsidize them
down
and
even not on the global level but it is
necessary that we
start to increase the supply with gas
with fuel with all the things to make it
feasible for the countries to pay for
the build
so how will you get
fuel shortages
off the table reduce prices
we are now discussing with all these
countries that are
exploring oil and gas and
trying to convince them to increase
their capacities so this would help the
world market
now it's three months to the day
today that russia invaded ukraine you're
one of the very few world leaders who
actually still have a direct line to
vladimir putin
vladimir zelinski ukraine's president at
the world economic forum spoke of
putin's intention to cause maximum
damage the maximum loss of lives
many people are wondering whether putin
has lost touch with reality what is your
impression when you speak to him
this is a
brutal aggression
a very brutal war
and
it is really an imperialistic approach
he tries to conquer parts of the
territory of his neighbor country
and this is what we will not be will be
never we will never accept and this is
why it is necessary that we support the
ukraine as i already
mentioned and that we on the other hand
talk directly to putin saying him that
he should stop the war and that
the activity he is starting there the
war
will never have a good outcome for his
own country we should not
forget that the
sanctions for instance
are
having a very heavy impact on the
russian economy
today but also in the future they will
go back
in their opportunities of economic
development
for decades so they are will suffer and
they are suffering and for getting out
of this he has to stop the war
now the united nations says for the
first time there's some 100 million
people fleeing conflict on the move
around the globe
germany is negotiating also with many
countries to take illegal so-called
illegal migration migrants back
what will germany do what will you do as
g7 presidency
to open avenues for legal migration
we have to be aware that there are a lot
of
people
that
are in a very desperate situation that
are fleeing from the places they lived
because of war because of a lot of other
reasons and so we have a global
responsibility to support the refugees
where they are and this is what we
never should forget that there is a
responsibility not just starting if for
instance refugees are coming to the
western countries and trying to live
there we also have to do a lot at the
places where they live in
most cases they're just
fled to the neighbor country and this
neighbor country needs assistance for
being able to cope with the situation
on the other hand
it is obvious that there will be the
need for legal ways of migration for
instance to europe and that we have to
find a way to
cooperate with the countries where the
people are looking for the chances to to
start a better life in
european countries in other countries of
the world and
doing this is then also an answer to
fight against illegal migration because
this also needs cooperation between the
countries
making it feasible that people go back
to the country of origin if they cannot
stay in the country they wanted to go
i just want to talk about the sahara
region because it's a great source of
instability that leads to migration as
well how concerned are you that you
might be supporting the wrong side by
extending one of the mandates in mali
after the coup
we are supporting the united nations
with their activity in
sahel and especially in mali with this
so-called menusma mandate
and this is something that is good for
stabilization in the region
but we also state very clear that we
will never accept
a situation
where
there will be a fight with
the support of russian soldiers in mali
against the people so it is necessary
that they are going back to the past of
a democratic
perspective
you speak of a special responsibility
that you feel for contributing to the
future being a multi-polar world
how does germany's europe's colonial
past shape the way
you want to integrate particularly
african countries
germany but
all countries with the
colonial past
have to be very honest and admitting
that this past is
part of their history and that they have
responsibility for better relations with
the countries
for instance
in africa
and
doing this is also the basis for a good
relationship in the future and my view
is that the world will have a lot of
very influential countries
in the next decades that
are not just
russia china united states and europe
for instance it will be also a lot of
other countries and this is one of the
reasons why i for instance invited
indonesia and india
senegal and south africa or argentine
to
participate in our g7 meeting in germany
this year and this summer
because it's a starting point for
understanding the world it's something
that we have responsibility together for
and this is the basis for
a multilateral world where we not just
see a lot of different influential
countries but countries that cooperate
for a better future
what role does africa play in this are
you more up against china or russia here
without vision
africa
is
a continent with a lot of
countries that and states that
will have a
future that
is better than today that will have a
lot of people living there and so it is
necessary that we
do all which is
feasible to
make it happen that this will be a good
future and cooperation
economic cooperation
support in the development is the basis
for this what most surprised you on this
trip
it was very
good to discuss with the leaders and
understanding that they have a very
similar view to the world and that they
are also
sharing the willingness
of cooperation and this is
one of the outcomes of this
trip to three countries and just finally
just a few kilometers from where we are
sitting right now nelson mandela was
elected the first democratically elected
president of south africa
if you could meet him today
what would you tell him or ask him
he was really a very great leader
and working intensely for freedom and
democracy and
i think
there is not a question i should have
asked him
but the question all asked him really is
how did you make it to state that
situation
in the jail for that long time and
keeping to be a very democratic leader
it is really a great man
olaf schwarz chancellor of germany on
his first trip to africa thank you very
much thank you
you